but it gets down to it though when you
have to get into business and you have
to create a hit song okay because let's
face it the hits have to come keep going
yes right how do you do how are you
staying in touch with with everything
that happens musically because the more
famous you get the more successful you
get sort of the more removed you are
from the local street scene so how how
the hell are you staying in touch with
all these beats and everything else
empower you empower people around you
all the time and you teach them what you
learned on the way you know to get to
the level that you're at and always
they're the ones that have their ear to
the ground they know what's going on and
never be afraid of constructive
criticism and never look for a hit
the minute you look it hides the minute
you chase it it runs that's so true have
fun in making it what's the push now you
got the the radio channel how happening
you're doing uh concerts are you in the
studio recording new stuff i i don't go
to the studio and record i i record
either on in any hotel room that i'm at
or on the boat or any chance i get i
have the engineer with me all the time
you mean to tell me that the technology
is so good now that you don't literally
need to go to a studio and and how does
that work in other words i'm sitting in
a hotel room with you and you say hey i
got a great idea for a song we get the
bed we put it up against the wall we get
the pillows we make our own sound booth
put up the mic and and is that true i
should yeah on my camera because i was
gonna say yeah you got to have a you
need a sound kind of that's what the
engineer is for so the engineer will be
able to mix the record because you got
to mix the record how do you record the
music the beat's already done so they
send the beats over and then i'm you
know knocking out ideas on it but i
think i'm gonna tell you what i don't
like about the studios when you get to
the studio it's all about whose dick is
bigger contest you know so
this guy got a bugatti so this guy's
gonna go get the new bugatti
this guy got a chain and this guy's
going to get the bigger chain and then
they're in the studio you know amongst
each other always talking and
so by the time you guys finish the
conversation i knocked out at least two
three records